لذا فإن تقاويم بوتين لعام 2020 قد تم
طرحها بالفعل على الرفوف هنا ، وستكون سعيدًا
بمعرفة ما إذا كانوا يفعلون كل عام
الرئيس الروسي في لقاءات مختلفة
هناك تقاويم متعددة هذا العام
مع تركيز قوي أعتقد أنه من العدل أن
نقول عن دبلوماسية بوتين
تم تصوير رجل روسي قوي مع العديد من
قادة العالم بما في ذلك صورة واحدة له وهو
جالس بجانب الرئيس الأمريكي ترامب
إيمانويل ماكرون من فرنسا والمستشارة الألمانية
أنجيلا ميركل بوتين كما
تظهر ابتسامة مع ولي
عهد المملكة العربية السعودية محمد بن
سلمان ومشاهدة الجودو  مباراة مع
شينزو أبي من اليابان بالطبع ،
يراقب الكرملين عن كثب
الصورة العامة لفلاديمير بوتين في
التقويمات السابقة لبوتين التي تضمنت
رئيسًا عاري الصدر يركب حصانًا أو
يصطاد ، لكن يبدو أنه هذا العام
بعد سلسلة من الشخصيات البارزة
النجاحات الدبلوماسية الروسية ، خاصة في
الشرق الأوسط ، فإن صورة بوتين
كرجل دولة دولي هي
التي تفضل عدم وجودها  جميع البدلات
وربطات العنق على الرغم من أن أحد تقاويم بوتين
مكرس بالكامل لحبه المبلّغ عنه
للحيوانات بوتين مع كلاب مختلفة
يغذي بوتين غزالًا صغيرًا بالحليب.
فهد ، الرسالة المقصودة
هي أنني أعتقد أنه من الواضح جدًا أن هذا
لا يزال رئيسًا قويًا على الرغم من
كونه في السلطة لأكثر من 20 عامًا لم
يعد معزولًا على الرغم من استمرار
العقوبات الدولية ضد روسيا ،
ولكن مع جانبه الأكثر ليونة ، فإن علاقته الظاهرة
بالطبيعة لا تزال
سليمة إلى حد كبير ماثيو  فرصة CNN موسكو